[موسيقى
] تعلم أنها كانت نقطة توقف في
تاريخ البشرية عندما تغلب جهاز كمبيوتر على
أعظم لاعب شطرنج كاسباروف
وفجأة اعتقدنا جيدًا أن هذه
نهاية حقبة لسنوات بعد ذلك
لا يستطيع أي لاعب شطرنج منافسة
جهاز كمبيوتر  ثم اكتشفوا أنه
عندما يلعب الإنسان والكمبيوتر
معًا ، يمكنهم التغلب على أي آلة
ويمكنهم التغلب على أي إنسان ، وأعتقد
أن هذا ما يبدو عليه المستقبل
[موسيقى] ، فإن
هذه الأنظمة ليس لديها
منطق منطقي مثلما نفعل  تتطلب
الملايين من الأمثلة المصنفة يدويًا
وليس هناك العديد من المجالات التي تتمتع بهذا الفخامة
، ولذا يتعين علينا حقًا تطوير
المجال الذي يتعين علينا حقًا إنشاء
خوارزميات الجيل التالي الأكثر
قدرة مما يمكن أن تفعله خوارزميات اليوم ،
ويمكننا إنشاء أنظمة تظهر
مشتركة  - التفكير المنطقي تمامًا كما
يفعل الناس ، وفي النهاية التحديات الكبرى ،
يمكننا عكس هندسة الدماغ ، ويمكننا
فهم ما يحدث بالفعل
معنا وما هي العمليات التي
مسؤولون عن سلوكنا الذكي
لأننا إذا فهمنا
أننا سنفهم أنفسنا ومن ثم
سنكون قادرين على هندسة الآلات
التي ستدعمنا في مهامنا المعرفية
[الموسيقى] ،
فقد كان هناك الكثير من النقاش حول تنظيم الذكاء الاصطناعي
وما إذا كان كذلك
من الممكن أن أكون في هذه القمة هنا ولذا بالنسبة
لي ، لا تزال هذه الأيام مبكرة جدًا ومن
الأهمية بمكان بالنسبة لحكومتنا أن تركز
أكثر على كيفية إدخال الذكاء الاصطناعي وتسريع
الابتكار والآن نحن
لا نعرف حتى قدرات
مختلف  أنظمة الذكاء الاصطناعي تمامًا مثل
الربط ، فهذا شيء بعيد المنال
[موسيقى]